[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hello,
I am Magnus Hyttsten
for "The Developer Show."
We're here at the
TensorFlow Dev Summit.
Next to me, I have Zak Stone.
Hi, Zak.
ZAK STONE: Hi, Magnus.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So I hear
that you're the person
to talk to about TPUs.
Is that correct?
ZAK STONE: Oh, there's
a huge team working
on TPUs all across the company,
but I'm definitely involved.
I'm real excited about
bringing a lot more performance
to the TensorFlow community.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Cool.
So can you describe what the
TPU is and what you use it for?
ZAK STONE: Sure.
Google has developed a
system of ASICs, boards,
and entire supercomputers
to accelerate performance
in machine learning.
So we needed this for
internal purposes, initially.
There was concern
several years ago that,
if every Android phone
user spoke to their phone
for a few minutes a
day, with algorithms
of the time on big
fleets of CPUs,
Google might need to double
the number of data centers.
And so that didn't make sense.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Wow.
ZAK STONE: Right?
And so there's
this crash program
to develop a chip that was
specialized to accelerate
some of these machine
learning workloads.
And so that was Google's
first TPU, which
was announced at Google
I/O, I think, two years ago.
So then last year,
we revealed that we
have the second
generation system, the TPU
v2, that's also available
now in Cloud as a Cloud TPU.
It's just recently gone to beta.
And so this supports
training and inference.
It's 180 teraflops per device.
And then these devices
can be connected together
into these TPU pods that go
up to 11 and 1/2 petaflops,
and so--
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: 11
and 1/2 petaflops?
ZAK STONE: Exactly.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's amazing.
ZAK STONE: Let me put
that in context for you.
So if you're training an
image recognition model--
let's say ResNet
50, it's the sort
of standard benchmark right now.
It was state of the
art not too long ago.
And if you want to train that
to 75% or 76% accuracy, which
is what you'd expect from
publications on the subject,
that might previously have
taken you days a few years
ago, when that
paper was published.
Now that's down to
about 12 and 1/2 hours
on one of these Cloud TPUs.
And on the full TPU pod, you
can do that in less than 12
and 1/2 minutes.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's amazing.
ZAK STONE: Yeah.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So I bet
you're all wondering out there,
how can I get my hands
on one of these things?
ZAK STONE: That's right.
Well, they're in beta
right now, so you have
to request quota at the moment.
But soon, we'll lift
that requirement,
and you'll be able
to just fire up
a Cloud TPU as
infrastructure, just like you
would a virtual machine.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So it's
not like you can go and buy
one and install on
your local hard--
the computer or anything.
ZAK STONE: That's right.
You go to cloud.google.com/tpu,
and you'd fill out the quota
form.
Or if you're already in
touch with Google Cloud
in some other way, just talk to
your contact at Google Cloud.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's amazing.
ZAK STONE: Yes.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: 180 teraflops,
ladies and gentlemen.
ZAK STONE: I know.
Another possibility.
We also have this TensorFlow
Research Cloud, which
is a set of 1,000 of these.
So together, that's
180 petaflops.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: 180?
Awesome.
ZAK STONE: 180 petaflops.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Oh, my gosh.
ZAK STONE: And those, we're
making available at no cost
through an application process
to top ML researchers out
in the community.
Because what we're
really trying to do
here is accelerate the rate of
progress in machine learning.
And so we know
that performance is
one of the main gating factors.
A lot of the amazing
results you've
seen across vision, and speech,
and language, and robotics,
and other things,
have really been
driven by this massive
increase in the amount
of available computation
and reduction in cost.
And so we're trying to
make ML acceleration
universally
accessible and useful,
affordable for everybody,
and available at scale
in the Cloud.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's great.
So 180 teraflops, all the
way up to 180 petaflops.
This is Magnus Hyttsten.
I'm here with Zak Stone.
We're at the
TensorFlow Dev Summit,
and this is "The
Developer Show."
[MUSIC PLAYING]